RONALD SMITH: Well, so we're
talking about the
general circulation
of the atmosphere.
Very important, very
broad subject.
And I'm going to re-hash a
couple of things here, just to
get us started on
today's lecture.
But I did bring us to the point
last time of looking at
a kind of a textbook cartoon
like this, that outlines in
very simple form the three cell
circulation model for the
Earth's atmosphere.
You know, in its most
basic form, this is
a very simple problem.
You're just putting more heat
in near the equator, and
taking more heat out near the
pole, and the differential
heating causes a circulation.
But the nature of that
circulation becomes rather
complicated because, well, of
the spherical geometry of the
Earth, the fact that the Earth
is spinning, which distributes
the solar heat pretty well
zonally around the equator,
but then the other big thing
is the Coriolis force.
We're going to be talking about
Coriolis force today in
some detail, but for right now,
I'll just mention it as
one of the reasons it gives
rise to this three cell,
rather complex structure.
Now of these three cells, the
one that is the easiest to
see, in day to day weather, in
satellite images, is the
Hadley cell.
So if you're not going to
memorize everything on this,
be sure you know the
Hadley cell.
That represents the rising air
near the equator, poleward air
moving aloft, and then sinking
and then returning towards the
equator at the surface of the
earth in a kind of a symmetric
way around the equator.
We'll see it's a little more
complicated than that, but
this is a good starting point.
It's a double kind of a
circulation pattern driven by
the excess heat put in from
the sun along the equator.
That's the Hadley cell.
The Ferrel cell is less easy to
see in the data, and so is
the Polar cell, but what's
easy to see are these
westerlies.
Here you have easterly flow
near the surface, here
westerlies, and we'll talk about
that, as well as this
being the belt of storms, which
I'll define for you in
just a moment.
Now, I showed these last time
but they're so loaded with
information and detail that
I wanted to say a few
more words about it.
What this is, is a composite
of several--
Let me get my global up
here for a minute.
So, the globe is spinning,
of course, like this.
But there are several satellites
in orbit of a type
called geostationary
satellites.
If you put a satellite in orbit,
approximately this far
from Earth, about 42,000
kilometers, the time it takes
to go once around in its orbit
just happens to be 24 hours.
The time it takes to go around
depends on the radius of that
orbit, and that particular
radius takes
24 hours to go around.
Well, if in addition, you've
put that satellite into an
equatorial orbit, and put it in
the pro-grade direction, so
it's moving from west to east,
I think you can see where I'm
going with this, then as the
Earth spins around, that
satellite stays over
the same point.
So, Earth is spinning once every
24 hours, it takes 24
hours for the satellite to go
around, that's called the
geostationary satellite.
The beauty of that is, that then
it looks like the Earth
is just fixed, and you can
see all the cloud motions
beautifully.
OK, now you're only seeing one
side of the Earth, but in fact
there are several of these
geostationary satellites in
orbit at the present time.
The United States has two, the
Europeans have one, the
Indians have one, the Japanese
have one, all generally in
their part of the world.
And so, you've got multiple
geostationary satellites.
So with a little bit of computer
wizardry, you can
stitch those movies together,
and make something like this.
Now, as you'll see, there are
an occasional little gap in
the data where something
went wrong.
The other thing is that
we're not looking
at reflected sunlight.
You would think, well,
the clouds are white.
No, we're not looking at
reflected sunlight.
Notice that the full globe
seems to be illuminated.
How could that be?
There's always a day side and
a night side, so you could
never have a situation
like that.
Well, we're not looking
at reflected sunlight.
We're looking at emitted
radiation in the thermal
infrared, the TIR.
The wavelengths being used here
are roughly in the range
of eight to twelve microns.
There happens to be in
atmospheric window there which
allows those photons to move
through the atmosphere without
being strongly absorbed.
And therefore, what we're seeing
is the intensity of
that radiation emitted by the
earth reaching the satellite.
In the areas where there are
no clouds, we're seeing
radiation emitted from the land,
and the land is hot.
So the radiation is strong.
In other areas where there
are high clouds, those
cloud tops are cold.
They emit less intensely,
and we show that
with kind of a false--
Notice we've kind of inverted
the color scheme.
It's actually the radiation
coming from here is large, the
radiation coming from there is
small, but we're-- we've coded
this as white and this as black,
in order to make it
look a little bit like reflected
sunlight, so the
clouds look white.
So we're trying to play a trick
on you, or all of us, by
coding that emitted radiation
to make it look a little bit
like clouds are white and land
is dark and ocean is dark.
So don't be fooled
by that, this is
really emitted radiation.
So it's a temperature map, but
we can easily find these high
clouds because they are higher
up in the troposphere.
Remember, it gets colder as
you go up, so those high
clouds have a colder
temperature
and they emit less.
There's no doubt that these
are clouds all right, but
we're seeing them because they
emit less radiation.
Any questions on that?
So then when I put this into
motion, I want you to watch
for various things here.
I think I'll start it
and then stop it.
So you're seeing clouds
generally along in the
equatorial region.
These are high, deep, convective
clouds with heavy
rain under them, and they're
generally moving from east to
west. We'll see in just a minute
that they're moving
along with the easterly trade
winds in those latitudes.
Whereas in--
down here and up here, you're
seeing these comma shaped
clouds, notice they're upside
down in the south, so the
commas look like this in the
north, but they're kind of
reversed in the south.
We'll see later today that has
to do with the flip in the
sign of the Coriolis force.
And they're generally moving
from west to east because this
is a belt of westerlies.
Westerly winds, or winds moving
from west to east, and
they're carrying those
storms eastward.
In between, there are belts
where there are
fewer clouds, and that--
fewer clouds, of course, means
less rain as well, so this
happens to be the belt of
deserts, for example, the
Sahara Desert lies in that
range, and so does some
deserts in Argentina,
and Africa, and
Australia, and so on.
So we're going to be spending a
lot of time on understanding
the distribution of climate
around the globe, but here's
our first hint at how this whole
system works, when we're
studying the general
circulation.
So let me finish up this
little film loop.
And then I'll move on to the
next, which is very similar,
except it's taken in a
different wavelength.
Instead of near 10 microns, it's
about 6.7 microns, which
is not a window.
It's not a wavelength for
which the atmosphere is
transparent.
It's actually a wavelength
for which the
atmosphere is rather opaque.
It's opaque because water
vapor absorbs at that
particular wavelength.
So we call this a water vapor
image, because the radiation
you're seeing there is coming
from water vapor molecules in
the atmosphere.
I think they look really cool,
because you start to see, it
looks like you're making some
kind of a cake, and you're
stirring the chocolate
in with the vanilla.
You see the dry and the moist
air kind of being mixed in
together in these mid latitude
frontal cyclones.
You still see the clouds all
right, the clouds show up just
as they did before, but in
addition you're seeing the
water vapor that's in and
around those clouds.
And there's a dry zone in the
north and south in these belts
of deserts, and then there's
moisture, again, down here,
being stirred in both high--
northern and southern
mid-latitudes by
these frontal cyclones.
Let me put this into motion.
So again, you see the general
sense of motion, east to west
through here, but west to
east here and here.
I'll finish up that loop.
Any questions on this?
Yes?
STUDENT: The tropical
rainforest, like in the
Amazon, falls into that area
that you said there aren't
like that many clouds but how
does it rain so often there?
PROFESSOR: Well, this is one
season of the year.
So, this one happens
to be September.
And this belt of cloudiness,
that you see over the oceans
and then down over the
continents, we call it the
Intertropical Convergence Zone,
and I'll define it in
just a moment, but it does move
a little bit with season.
But it is those clouds that
is responsible for the
rainforests.
But you want to take a look at
the whole year to see when
it's going to be raining there,
and when it might not
be raining.
So this is only a few days in
September, and it doesn't give
you the full picture.
But we'll talk about the
seasonality of this in a
couple days, and I think that'll
answer your question.
But basically, yes.
The rainforests are connected
with this belt of rain and
cloudiness, but perhaps not at
the exact September moment
that I'm showing here.
OK, I think I can move
on to the next.
So we're going to be speaking
on this subject together for
the next week or two, and
we'll be failing to
communicate unless we have
a common terminology.
And so, I just want to be sure
that you understand these
terms before I go any further.
First of all, I've broken
this into kind of
zones at various latitudes.
And the first one I want to talk
about is what's called
the equatorial zone.
Of course, it's the zone going
around the Earth east to west.
Some authors differ on these
definitions, but for the
present purposes I'm going to
say from five degrees north to
five degrees south around the
globe will be what we call the
equatorial zone.
Some of the things that goes
on in that zone is that at
least part of the year, that's
where the Intertropical
Convergence Zone is.
That's where the northeast and
the southeast trade winds
converge at low levels, and
cause rising air, which goes
back to the question
was just asked.
And in there somewhere will
be the belt of rainforest,
because it's that rain that
produces that kind of ecology,
that forest that's adapted to
receiving a whole lot of rain
every year.
This word doldrums, you'll
often find in the--
sometimes in the scientific
literature, sometimes in the
broader literature, it refers
to a region over the oceans
where the winds are
usually very weak.
And that's because you're right
in between these two
trade wind zones.
So in the early days, when the
sailors were trying to travel
across the equator, they would
often become becalmed in this
zone, and then the name doldrums
came from that
experience.
Then as we go north and south
a little bit more, north or
south, we enter what's
called the tropics.
And again, authors may differ
a little bit on their
definitions.
I've defined it as being five
degrees to 23 degrees.
Now I mean by that five degrees
north, to 23 north,
and five south to 23 south.
So I'm referring to both the
northern and southern
hemisphere tropics.
Now I'm sure you know where that
23 comes from, actually
should be 23 1/2 degrees.
The tilt of the Earth is 23 1/2
degrees from normal to the
plane of the ecliptic, and based
on that we define the
so-called Tropics of Cancer and
Capricorn, that at least
in the traditional literature,
define what
we mean by the tropics.
It's not so precise when
we're applying it to
meteorology and climate.
It's more of an astronomical
definition of the tropics than
it is a climatological
definition, but that's OK,
it's close enough for
our purposes.
So in most cases I'm happy to
define the tropics in that way
as being these two belts from
about five degrees up to the
Tropics of Capricorn
and Cancer.
In that region is where you
have these steady easterly
trade winds, and the Hadley
cell is operating in both
hemispheres, generally in
that range of latitudes.
Any questions so far on this?
Well, the sub tropics then,
we'll take to be from 23--
and here authors again differ
quite a bit, I'm going to take
it 23 to 35, so it's
somewhere in here.
Florida would be in
the sub tropics.
Generally you've got high
pressure, slightly higher
average pressure around the
globe in that belt.
So it's called sometimes the
STHP, the Subtropical High
Pressure, it's also the belt of
deserts, it's where the air
in the Hadley cell
is descending.
And you know what that means,
when air descends, it
compresses adiabatically, it
warms, and the relative
humidity decreases.
That air becomes drier and drier
in the sense of relative
humidity, so you're unlikely
to get clouds and
precipitation in any area where
the air is descending,
therefore that's the
belt of deserts.
Over the oceans, it has
a special name.
In the open literature,
sometimes it's called the
horse latitudes.
That too is a reversal point,
because you've got easterly
trade winds equatorward of that,
and westerlies poleward
of that, so there's a zone,
again, where the average winds
are very weak.
The tradition of this term is
a bit odd, but in the early
days, the Spanish were carrying
horses to the New
World, and when they became
becalmed in the middle of the
Atlantic ocean, and their water
and their food ran out,
of course, the horses would die
or they'd be eaten by the
sailors, and then the carcasses
would be thrown overboard.
So a later sailor or ship
sailing through that region,
would find the carcasses of dead
horses floating in the
ocean, it became known as
the horse latitudes.
But what that really is
referring to is the fact that
there's generally weak
winds there.
So if you're depending on the
wind for your propulsion, then
that's a difficult part
of the ocean to cross.
Questions on that?
OK, then we get into
mid latitudes.
That's where we live.
New Haven's latitude is about
41 degrees north, so we're
clearly in that.
Generally it's a zone of
westerlies, it's the belt of
frontal storms, remember all
those little comma clouds we
saw zipping from west to east?
That really characterizes
this part of the world.
The jet stream is here, and
the so-called polar front,
which is a boundary between
colder air to the north and
warmer air to the south in the
northern hemisphere is found
in the mid-latitude zone.
So, these are all really
important terms. Are there any
questions on them?
OK.
Now, the general circulation
is pretty complicated.
And other aspects of atmospheric
motion such as
storm development are
pretty complicated.
And in a course like this, we
can't go into all the details,
but I did want to give you a
broad outline of how the
atmosphere moves.
What drives it, and kind of
what effects what effects
what, cause and effect
around the loop.
I constructed this diagram,
which I'm simply calling
atmospheric dynamics, it's kind
of a box diagram that
tries to point out some
of the causality.
The reason I think it's
appropriate to bring in at
this point in the course, is
that you've already dabbled
with a number of
these concepts.
So I think you can appreciate
the way some of
these linkages work.
Let me run through
it very briefly.
And this applies, by the way,
not only to the general
circulation, but to really
every type of atmospheric
motion, including sea breezes
and thunderstorms, everything
kind of works off this in
one way or another.
So, differential heating is the
ultimate cause of all the
atmospheric motion
on our planet.
And of course, it would cause
temperature differences.
It would heat up some parts of
the Earth more than others,
the air in that region would
become warmer or cooler
relative to other regions.
Now, the temperature differences
generally cause
density differences.
We can understand that
partially through
the perfect gas law.
Although remember, there are
three variables in the perfect
gas law, not just two.
But generally, temperature
differences give rise to
density differences,
as we have argued
before in this course.
Density differences give rise
to pressure differences, not
so much through the perfect
gas law, but through the
hydrostatic law.
In other words, if I have
cold, dense air here,
hydrostatically, it's
going to have higher
pressure beneath it.
If I have warm, less dense air
over here, hydrostatically,
it's going to have lower
pressure beneath it So it's
largely through the hydrostatic
law that we
develop pressure differences
on a horizontal plane, so
called sea level pressure
differences, or pressure
differences at other
horizontal levels.
The pressure differences want
to make the air move.
Like when I pucker up and blow
through my lips, high pressure
in my cheeks, low pressure in
the room, the air wants to
move under the influence of
that pressure difference.
Now, the atmosphere doesn't
work exactly like that, as
I'll talk about later today.
But generally, pressure
differences want to get the
air moving.
In this case, however, the law
that controls that to a first
approximation, is the
geostrophic law, which I'll be
talking about later today.
And then it loops back on
itself, because the wind will
have an influence back on the
temperature of the air.
It does that in two ways.
If I've got cold air here, and
the wind is blowing, it's
going to carry that cold air
to a different location.
Last time we talked about if air
moves, heat moves too, and
that's what I'm talking
about here.
So, air will advect from one
place to another, carrying its
temperature field with it, so
that's going to cause a change
in some region's temperature.
And the other thing, if air
converges horizontally, and
air rises, then you get
adiabatic cooling.
Or if air descends, you
get adiabatic warming.
So, there's a couple of ways
in which the wind can
influence the temperature, and
then the loop just continues.
So, in order to understand
atmospheric dynamics, one has
to understand how all
of these things work
together in a system.
And if you took a course in
fluid mechanics or in
atmospheric dynamics, you'd be
learning how to deal with that
simultaneous and consistent
action of
all of those variables.
But you already, with your
knowledge, can understand the
pieces, and we'll try to
describe how these different
systems work in terms
of how the pieces
play a role in that.
Any questions there?
OK, so we can't go any further
in atmospheric dynamics
without knowing about
the Coriolis force.
And here's just a few
bullet points.
The name comes from a
French mathematician
who discovered it.
He was hired by the French Army
to try to figure out why,
when they were developing longer
range cannons, that the
cannon was hitting
to the right--
the shells were hitting to the
right of where they aimed it.
They didn't notice it when the
cannons were firing only a
short distance, but as they
got longer and longer
trajectories, they noticed a
systematic bend to the right,
and he figured out it had to
do, of all things, with the
rotation of the Earth.
Pretty fundamental discovery.
Now what is the Earth rotate
with respect to?
There's always a question
of whether there is some
reference frame, some ultimate
Newtonian reference frame,
from which one can measure
such things as the
rotation of the Earth.
Well, it seems like there is.
If you look at the most distant
stars and use that as
a reference frame, and measure
the rotation of the Earth
relative to that, I think we've
convinced ourselves, I
think it's true, that
that is the absolute
rotation of the Earth.
We can take those distant
stars as zero rotating
inertial reference frame.
So when I say rotation of the
Earth, that's what I'm
referring to.
As we'll see when we do some
examples today, it's in some
sense you might consider to
be a rather weak force.
You've probably never noticed
it as you walked around are
throwing baseballs or footballs,
you've probably
never noticed the
Coriolis force.
Nevertheless, it is acting, but
it's only when you get up
to larger scale systems, such
as the atmosphere and the
ocean that it turns out
to be important.
And not just important,
but actually,
in some ways dominant.
In some ways it it's the most
important force that acts on
the atmosphere and the ocean.
It has the characteristic, the
odd characteristic of always
being a deflecting force.
In other words, whatever motion
you already have with
your object, it doesn't try to
speed you up or slow you down,
it just tries to turn you.
So it's always just a
deflecting force.
It acts at right angles
to the motion vector.
I'll come back to that.
And who's ever seen a
Foucault pendulum?
Show of hands.
Only a few of you.
Well, it's a remarkable way to
see the action of the Coriolis
force, it is evident in
a Foucault pendulum.
So, I'm going to take
a minute just to
describe a Foucault pendulum.
So, imagine that I've take a
string and brought it down
from the ceiling, and put a
massive weight on it, like
your coffee urn here, and I
get it swinging back and
forth, just as a simple
pendulum.
Turns out that if you can design
a pendulum that will--
of course, that would probably
damp out in half an hour and
we wouldn't see any motion.
But if it's a massive enough
bob, that weight on the end of
the pendulum's called a bob,
it might keep going for
several hours, or even
a day or so.
And if you did that, you'd begin
to notice that the plane
of that oscillation would
begin to rotate.
And this is why, because we're
looking down now at the
pendulum, so it's swinging back
and forth like this, and
when it's moving in this
direction, this is a Coriolis
force, it's acting to deflect it
to the right of the motion.
Well that's going to put it
probably over onto this
trajectory, but then when it's
swinging back in the other
direction, again the Coriolis
force acts to the right of the
motion, the motion has reversed,
and so has the
Coriolis force.
So that's going to rotate
the plane of that
oscillation even more.
So you can see, slowly through
time the plane of that
oscillation is going to rotate,
in this case I've
drawn the Coriolis force acting
to the right of the
motion vector.
And so, the Foucault pendulum's
going to precess in
the clockwise direction, the
clockwise direction, through
the action of the
Coriolis force.
Here's a picture of one.
And I'm not sure which one this
is, but they've done the
same trick that I've seen in
the one in the Smithsonian.
And that is, they put little
markers along here, so that
you can go look at the pendulum
and go visit some
other exhibits in the museum,
and then come back a couple
hours later and see whether
new markers have
been knocked down.
And if they have, that will give
you an indication of the
procession of the plane
of that oscillation.
And notice here, these have
been knocked down,
and these have not.
So we can see that thing is
processing in this direction
here, and you see these
have been knocked down
here, and not these.
So indeed, this one must be in
the Northern hemisphere,
because it is processing in
the clockwise direction.
Is that clear?
Questions on this?
This is a Foucault pendulum.
Wonderful way for seeing this
marvelous, mysterious force
that is so important in the
atmosphere and the ocean.
Anything?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Does that mean that in
the Southern Hemisphere it
goes counterclockwise?
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
It would go opposite in the
Southern Hemisphere, it would
go in a counterclockwise
direction.
STUDENT: Does that have
anything to do
with flushing a toilet?
PROFESSOR: I'll get to that.
I've got a subject today called
toilet bowl mythology,
which I'll get to.
Thanks for the question.
So, this thing called a Coriolis
force, there's a
nice, simple formula for
it, and here it is.
The magnitude of the Coriolis
force is given by the mass of
the object, times 2 times
the speed of the object.
I'm using capital Greek letter
Omega to represent the
rotation rate of the Earth and
the sine of the latitude.
Rotation rate of the Earth once
around is 2 pi radians.
It takes one day to do that,
so if I express that in SI
units, that'll be units of
radians per second, or just
inverse seconds, and
the value is this.
Now being in this field, I carry
that number around in my
head, but there's no
reason for you to.
Also, it's so easy
to re-derive.
You just put 2 pi up front, and
then figure out how many
seconds there are in a day, and
divide by that, and you'l
get that famous number, capital
Omega, the rotation
rate of the Earth, expressed
in radians per second.
Question?
STUDENT: What is U? and omega?
PROFESSOR: Use the speed of the object.
Omega is the rotation
right of the Earth.
Phi is the latitude
that you're at.
So that tells you about
the magnitude of it.
The direction, the formula
doesn't tell
you, but you can remember.
In the Northern hemisphere, it
acts to the right of the
motion vector.
In the Southern hemisphere,
it acts to the left
of the motion vector.
Remember, there always has to
be motion, if there's no
motion, there's no
Coriolis force.
So there always has to be-- the
Coriolis force only acts
on moving objects.
If an object is stationary in
the Earth reference frame,
there's no Coriolis force
acting on it.
So there's never any ambiguity
about the direction, because
it already has a motion, and we
use that to figure out what
direction of the Coriolis
force is.
Julia?
STUDENT: So even with--so you
were saying when you throw a
football you dont see the
Coriolis force, is that just
'cause the distance you throw
it isnt long enough?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, long
enough to see it, exactly.
If you were some Superman that
could fire it 4-5 kilometers,
it would land a meter or
so to the right of
where you threw it.
But, you know, a normal football
quarterback doesn't
throw it that far.
STUDENT: So does that act
on anything that moves?
PROFESSOR: Anything that moves.
STUDENT: Like even a car?
PROFESSOR: Anything, anything.
As I'm walking across this
floor, there's a Coriolis
force acting on me
at the moment.
I can't feel it because it's
too small, but it's there.
Anything that moves on the
earth feels the Coriolis
force, whether it's a--
well, just anything at all,
anything that moves.
Absolutely.
And there's no Coriolis
force at the equator.
And you'll see that right here,
because if you put in
zero degrees for latitude
at the equator, the
sine of zero is zero.
And so, there's no Coriolis
force at the equator, and of
course it's strongest
at the poles.
At the poles, latitude is 90,
the sine of 90 is one, and you
get everything else here
for the strength of
the Coriolis force.
Questions there?
Let me do a little example, I
put one up on the board here.
I've written that same formula
out, did I get it right?
Yes.
Let's say we've got a mass of
one kilogram, at a latitude of
30 degrees north, moving at 10
meters per second, on Earth,
so there's the rotation
rate of Earth.
I plug it into the formula, one
kilogram times two, times
the speed, times the
rotation rate.
The sine of 30 degrees, if you
don't remember, is 0.5.
That comes out to be
7.27 times ten to
the minus four Newtons.
That's a force unit
in the SI system.
And what direction
does it act?
Well, it depends on what
direction the motion is.
I haven't told you that.
If the object is moving towards
the northeast, the
Coriolis force will be towards
the southeast. If the object
happens to be moving towards
the southeast, the Coriolis
force will be towards the
southwest. So always to the
right of the motion vector,
whatever the motion vector is.
Coriolis force.
Now, here's where it comes
in to the atmospheric
application.
Very often, we find that air
is moving along, around the
atmosphere, in the atmosphere,
in a state
of geostrophic balance.
Geostrophic balance
is a particular
kind of force balance.
Remember hydrostatic balance was
a kind of force balance,
it's a balance between weight
and the vertical pressure
gradient force.
Well, this is more of a force
balance in the horizontal.
So it's horizontal forces that
we're talking about.
Pressure gradient force and the
Coriolis force, when they
come into balance, we call that
geostrophic, geo meaning
Earth, stroph coming from
a root meaning turning.
So you know it has to do
something with the turning of
the Earth, well, in this
case it has to do with
the Coriolis force.
It results in some very odd
things that I'll show you, as
we move through this section.
For example, the wind blows
parallel to the isobars
instead of across them.
And the speed of the wind is
related to the isobar spacing.
The geostrophic force balance
applies actually most of the
time in the free atmosphere.
I hesitate to give you a number,
but I would say maybe
90 or 95% of the time, when
you're above the boundary
layer, the air is moving along
at a pretty good state of
geostrophic force balance.
This is why it's so important
for us to understand this
particular characteristic
of the atmosphere.
It is invalid, however, you do
not have geostrophic force
balance down in the frictional
boundary layer, where there's
a lot of turbulence, or in
strong storms or other
disturbances.
So it's not universally
applicable, but it's widely
applicable.
Here's a little cartoon then,
of describing what I mean by
geostrophic balance.
So if I have--
this a plan form view.
So I'm looking down at the
surface of the Earth, north,
south, east, west. And if
there happens to be high
pressure to the south on this
particular day, and low
pressure to the north, then
there's going to be a pressure
gradient force acting on a
parcel of air sitting here
from high to low.
If I've got an object, no matter
how small it is, if
there's slightly higher pressure
on one side and lower
pressure on the other side,
there's going to be a net
force on that.
That net force is what we call
the pressure gradient force.
We call it a pressure gradient
force because it arises
because there is a gradient.
Gradient means a change in
pressure with position.
So, high pressure here, low
pressure there, means that
object is going have a slightly
higher pressure on
the southward side, a little
lower pressure on the northern
side, and the net force is
going to be to the north,
called the pressure
gradient force.
Now, if it's in geostrophic
balance, it has to have a
Coriolis force that is equal
and opposite to that.
This is a vector balance,
so the speed--
the magnitude and the direction
have to be exactly
opposite to that.
And here's how the
reasoning goes.
If the force must be like that,
then what must the air
be doing, how must
it be moving.
It must be moving, then, from
west to east, so that the
Coriolis force which is at right
angles to it, has the
orientation given by
the green vector.
So this is the only
consistent--
once I draw in that pressure
gradient force, than that
vector and that vector are
locked in, that's the only way
I can draw them if that's
air parcel is to be
in geostrophic balance.
These lines of constant pressure
are called isobars,
and you could label them with
a pressure, 1,020, 1,010,
1,000, 990; those are just lines
of constant pressure
drawn on a map called isobars.
And so, you'll notice that in
this circumstance, instead of
the air blowing from high
pressure to low, like you
would have expected, because
of the Coriolis force, it
moves along the isobars,
not across them.
Quite a surprise, because in
our common world, you know
blowing up a tire to a bicycle,
or whatever, air
tends to move from high
pressure to low.
But on a larger scale, where
the Coriolis force plays a
role, it's more like this.
Air moves along the isobars
rather than across them.
Questions here?
Now, so mathematically, we
want to write down an
expression for this geostrophic
balance, so let me
write that down.
First of all, I need a formula
for the pressure gradient
force, and that's given by the
pressure gradient times the
volume of the object.
The pressure gradient is defined
as the rate at which
pressure changes with
position, as units
of pascals per meter.
And the volume is just
the volume of the
object in cubic meters.
The mass of any object would be
given by its mass density
times its volume.
So, going back a couple of
slides where I have the
formula for the Coriolis force,
and adding these two
formulas to it, I can come up
with this very important,
slightly lengthy equation.
But on the left, is the pressure
gradient force given
by this, and on the right, is
the Coriolis force, given here
on the board still.
But for mass, I've put in the
product of the density and the
volume of the air parcel that's
being considered.
So now, we're not considering
any old object--
it's not a, car it's not a
freight train, it's not a
howitzer shell, it's a
little chunk of air.
We're trying to come up with a
geostrophic balance formula
for a chunk of air and rho is
the density of that air,
volume, 2U omega sine theta.
Now, the volumes are going to
cancel out from the left and
right, and I can solve this
formula for u, I'll put a
subsequent geostrophic on it,
it's given by the pressure
gradient divided by two rho
omega sine of the latitude.
This is a rather remarkable
formula.
It doesn't solve every problem
in atmospheric dynamics, but
it's still rather remarkable.
It says if you know something
about the pressure field, I
can tell you something
about the wind.
It's a relationship between
spatial variations in pressure
and the wind speed and
direction, called the
geostrophic formula.
Let's see.
Let me do the problem on
the board first, and
then we'll go on here.
Hope you can see this.
So again, we're looking down on
a map, north, south, east,
west. And on this particular
day, the
isobars look like this.
This one's labeled 1,012
millibars, 1,011, 1,010,
1,009, so these are lines of
constant pressure, isobars,
constant pressure.
And let's say for the sake of
argument that the spacing
between those isobars is
about 100 kilometers.
About 50 miles between these
different things.
So the pressure gradient is
derived as the rate at which
pressure changes with distance,
so it's going to be
one millibar divided
by that distance.
So it's delta P over L, one
millibar divided by 100
kilometers, that's 100 Pascals,
divided by 10 to the
fifth meters, so the answer
is 10 to the minus
3 Pascals per meter.
That's the pressure gradient,
the magnitude of the pressure
gradient in that region.
It's a reasonable value.
Now I'm ready to plug
it into the formula.
Let's see if I've transcribed
it right, pressure gradient
over two rho omega sine
of the latitude, OK.
The pressure gradient, we
decide, is 10 to minus three.
I'm going to use sea level
density, 1.2 kilograms per
cubic meter, here comes the
rotation rate of the Earth,
capital Omega.
And for this problem I'm going
to say we're in New Haven, the
latitude's around 42 north,
sine of 42 is about 0.67.
Plug all that in I get 0.08
times 10 to the two, and just
moving the decimal place
over, that's
eight meters per second.
So under this circumstance,
the speed would be eight
meters per second.
And I know what the direction
is going to be too, because
it's going to be parallel to
the isobars, with the high
pressure on the right.
High pressure on the right, so
that's going to be the wind
vector, eight meters per second,
under that kind of a
pressure situation.
Any questions on that?
An easy calculation to do, once
you know something about
how the how the isobars look.
Question there?
So, if I were to imagine another
isobar pattern that
was in the form of a circle,
or a bullseye, whenever you
have an isolated low pressure
region with high pressure all
the way around, it you normally
refer to that in
meteorology as a cyclone.
Sometimes the word cyclone
has other connotations.
It may imply some kind of severe
storm, or a tornado, or
something like that.
In the Wizard of Oz, when
Dorothy was sucked up into the
tornado, she was referring
to that as a cyclone.
Right?
Cyclone.
But in meteorology, it has
somewhat broader and less
dangerous meaning.
It's just a low pressure
center with a high
pressure around it.
And so, I've drawn the
isobars in this way.
And let's imagine a parcel
sitting there, kind of halfway
out from the center.
So, there's high pressure here,
and low pressure there,
so the pressure gradient force
is going to be from high to
low, so the red arrow's going
to be the pressure gradient
force, PGF.
If it's to be in geostrophic
balance, the Coriolis force
must be equal and opposite
to that.
And the only way, given the
properties of the Coriolis
force, the only way it can have
a Coriolis force in that
direction is if the wind
velocity was to the north.
Because then, the Coriolis force
is to the right of the
motion vector.
So I conclude, by that
reasoning, that the air must
be moving northwards, or I could
say it's a southerly
wind at that location.
If I repeated the calculation
there, and there, and there,
here I would find that the wind
must be blowing in that
direction, here I would find
it must be blowing in that
direction, here, in
that direction.
So in fact, the air must be
going around the cyclone in a
counterclockwise direction,
if we're in the Northern
hemisphere.
Is that clear?
So, low pressure, cyclone,
Northern hemisphere, air goes
around counterclockwise.
We say that's the cyclonic
direction, the air is moving
cyclonically around that
low pressure zone.
But now, we want to take a
somewhat broader view of this,
so I'm going to introduce--
OK, this is a big jump, but I
think we're ready to do this.
So, here's the equator.
So Northern hemisphere,
Southern hemisphere.
There's the problem I just
worked out, there's the low
pressure, and that's
called a cyclone.
I'm going to introduce an
anticyclone in the Northern
hemisphere.
And then in the Southern
hemisphere, I'm going to have
a cyclone and an anticyclone.
And we're going to understand
what way the wind blows around
each of these systems. Well,
let's stay in the Northern
hemisphere, with high pressure
in the center, the pressure
gradient forces it outwards, so
the Coriolis force must be
inwards, so the air must
go around this way.
It must go around in the
clockwise direction.
Around an anticyclone in the
Northern hemisphere.
In the Southern hemisphere,
we've got the low pressure in
the center again, because it's
a cyclone, but now, the
pressure gradient force is again
in towards the center.
But because the Coriolis force
acts to the left of the motion
vector, we end up with just
the opposite circulation,
direction to the circulation.
It's clockwise here, and
counterclockwise around the
anticyclone.
So, this is a weather map
taken from yesterday.
At 500 millibars, so about
five kilometers up in the
atmosphere, you can consider
these black
lines to be the isobars.
And they're from individual
balloon launches.
Every place there's a balloon
launch, they've picked off the
wind and speed and direction,
and put a wind barb at the
location of that
balloon launch.
And notice first of all, that
the wind vectors kind of
parallel the isobars.
There's high pressure down here,
low pressure up there,
you might expect the wind to be
blowing from high to low,
but no, it blows along
the isobars instead.
And that's what we expect from
geostrophic balance.
Notice also that the wind is
stronger here, it's getting up
to be 70 or 80 knots, where
the isobars are
packed closely together.
But where the isobars are far
apart, the wind is very weak.
We'll take a look at this
formula, this example we did
for a minute.
If those isobars were
further apart, then
the L would be greater.
If L is greater, the pressure
gradient is less, and putting
the pressure gradient into the
geostrophic formula, I get a
weaker wind.
So directly, whenever you have
closely spaced isobars, you
have strong winds.
Whenever the isobars are far
apart, you have weak winds.
That follows directly from
the geostrophic formula.
For example, here's a map,
and no winds are given.
This is a sea level
pressure map.
No winds are given.
What can you conclude
from this?
Well, a lot, now that you know
the geostrophic law.
Because you know that around the
anticyclone, the winds are
generally going in
this direction.
And because those isobars are
spaced out quite a bit,
there's a rather weak wind
blowing around here.
Here near this low pressure,
near this cyclone, with
closely spaced isobars, there
are very strong winds going
around in a counterclockwise
direction.
We're out of time, but we'll
continue this on Monday.
Have a good weekend.